ragazzi è breve nulla a nessuno ormai ci
ho preso gusto mentre stava letta carina
possiamo che mi chiama così lo ammazzo
molto facciamo prima oggi vi racconto
ragazzi una storia lina ecco tra tutte
le storie di rocket league che ho fatto
fino ad oggi questa forse la più recente
che ho raccontato durante un video
allora vi starete chiedendo se sono
sempre che in genere un titolo del
titolo così potrebbe essere quasi click
day tokay non lo è allora non so da che
parte cominciare perché veramente allora
veramente poche persone sanno di questa
storia che conosco ma io ve la racconto
ragazzi
partiamo allora questo sabato scorso ok
è uscito video po particolare sul mio
canale un regalo marco io ho fatto
insieme a dei bb.cc
un regalo per marco marino ok che in
quel video non si vede perché non si può
vedere un regalo un po al di là un po
ecco il regalo poco family friendly come
te volo così quindi non si può vedere
però l'ho tenuto conto perché fanno
purtroppo riedel e reaction nostre di
quando lo trasportiamo e le reaction che
a marco quando lo vedevi l'ho fatto lo
stesso invito e fa molto ridere
guardatelo se non avete visto che è
uscito poco fa questo regalo poi l'avete
capito nei commenti era prete allora
hanno aperto nel racconto hanno aperto
avevano aperto e se non so se c'è ancora
l'anno scorso su internet legge moglie
mi amici una notizia che a torino
avevano aperto questo centro di so come
chiamarlo tipo un bordello è però dvd di
bambole non erano bambole gonfiabili
ok ho fatte tipo tipo in silicone
secondo me sì ma aprile una cosa manca
per a ciò che sembra pelle dalla bambole
che sembrano persone proprio persone che
hanno aperto questa specie di bordelli
bambole faceva ridere questa questa cosa
e allora cosa abbiamo fatto cosa ho
fatto per coperto l'iniziativa io per
questa cosa marco stava per fare il
marco marino
bisogna saper fare 30 anni ok quindi che
cosa abbiamo deciso di fare per deciso
di regalargli una bambola di queste ok
allora io mi sono messo a cerchio a
cercare questa cosa su su internet per
ordinarla no e l'ho trovata
l'ho trovata ahimè gasco perché allora
gaze queste cose costano tantissimo ton
c'è tipo questo tipo migliaia alcune
quest anno migliaia di euro c'è sopra i
1000 c'è una roba costano tantissimo
quindi io sono riuscito perché ho dovuto
google ha già google harloff un problema
perché mi caps mia madre per caso è se
vista la cronologia nel mio computer
avrebbe detto io non conosco mio figlio
ecco avrebbe detto questa qui li io ho
dovuto googlare un po per trovare una
sorta di offerta perché costavano
veramente tanto ha dato al regalo era
più per fare un video molto celato
perché non si vede ovviamente niente col
video però è la più perfetta per per
raccontarla sta cosa è quindi ho fatto
insomma ho cercato le migliori offerte
per trovare insomma la migliore sul
mercato alla fine con uno sconto del 70
per cento a roba allucinante siamo
riusciti a riportarci alla casa di
potremmo stessi 500 va insomma non si
dice spero che marco non guardi questo
video che non si che non si dice quanto
spendi per un regalo però un regalo un
po strano quindi penso che non gliene
freghi una sega veniva bene tanto di sé
che si parlava niola mi arriva questa
tanto mentre mi è arrivata io l'ho
dovuta tenere in casa per due giorni
prima di portarla da marco perché io non
potevo portarla da parte che pesava un
sacco grandissima cosa quindi ricevuto
giampiero per portarsi vede che facciamo
fatica nel video a portarla ovviamente
tutt'altro l'abbiamo messa in un sacco
c'è sacco in un contenitore da
pianoforte
ok ti massacra pianoforte se fosse per
caso caduta per strada ci avrebbero
arrestati a tutti e due perché sembrava
un corpo uscito dalle gattare una
bambola quindi nero ancora però avrebbe
creato insomma dell'allarmismo capite
cioè ti casca una una sacca esce un
braccio dici no vabbè questi hanno
ammazzato
gli arresti amo grazie a dio non è
e già così fa ridere come si stasera che
se guardate quel video l'avete visto ora
capite tante cose fa ridere lui stato lo
portava giampiero io sono a posto
comunque è comunque gli avevo regalato
la bambola davamo è rimasta marco tutto
a posto insomma fin qua tutto è tutto
bene passano ragazzi un po di mesi di
questa situazione era ormai definita
regalo fatto ci sono divertiti mille
risate ci ho fatto già due video quindi
lo so spero non lo sarò mai ripagato ma
quasi per il tirchio che in me è anche
abbastanza a posto
vabbè passano dei mesi io vado in
vacanza a new york che io che se state
sono dato la scorsa estate sono andati
vacanza a new york
vado in vacanza a new york e vado in
vacanza con la mia ero con la mia ex a
new york mi sveglio la mattina o che era
ancora gente allagato abbastanza mi
svegli una mattina mi sveglio verso le 8
più o meno quindi presto le otto che in
italia in realtà è molto più tardi sono
sei ore avanti l'italia raja pomeriggio
mi sveglio e non riesco più ad
addormentare i che dopo un po che ero
sveglio allora iniziò a smanettare su
facebook perché scola home perché non
riuscivo ad addormentarmi no lei dormiva
me ne frega niente io faceva bene io ero
lì che scorre lavoravo perché non
riuscivo a dormire maledetto jet lag
scrollo la home di facebook
ragazzi questa ragazzi attenzione questa
è la parte più bella di tutto il video
notizie di cronaca ma attenzione notizie
di cronaca milanese che recitava le
seguenti parole li trovato corpo morto
in un lago
ok falso allarme alla fine si trattava
di una bambola e successo a milano starò
bano quindi io ho fatto due più due ho
detto no non è che marco se succede una
cosa del genere procuri un falso
all'ance creed e l'allarmismo perché poi
nella foto si erano mobilitati si vedeva
l'ambulanza svelano i carabinieri si
vedeva c'era una roba là dentro che
faceva paura si fecero mobilitati 20.000
detto madonna
un allarmismo imbarazzante questa cosa e
quindi a liszt e io l'ho letto harrison
ha detto capisce chi è il pirla che che
ha creato installarmi sopra poi ho
pensato detto milano marco abita
abbastanza vicino a un fiume
lì ho fatto due p2 detto no aspetta ma
non è che ho detto non ho fatto la mente
d'abito detto mica mi sono cagato
addosso perché ho detto mi chiese magari
poi questi qua cercano di risalire che
poi non è successo niente perché no una
bambola è però se più sicura risalgono a
ieri a comprare una bambola vanno a
vedere solo io le tonova baby che non ci
posso credere lo finisco sui giornali
per aver creato un allarmismo perché poi
avviene pensando sia stato io invece in
realtà detto no non ci posso credere
allora io in panica e roero nel letto
che con la mia ex ragazza non eletto mi
alzo immanicati ssimo e scudi casa ma
proprio non ero in mutande mi metti
pantone voci esco di casa chiamo marco
subito pronto marco e non risponde
perchè sabato il marco dovete sala chi
non conosce marco marino marco dorme
tanto marco dorme fino alle quattro del
pomeriggio perché va a dormire alle 8
c'è marco le marche e jet lag ato in
italia in contrario quindi ho chiamato
la prima show marco risponde lui
risponde valevano co vero risponde sulle
quattro l'italia porco demonio rispondi
ore 9 la luna nomi comunque era tardi
non rispondeva
allora chiamo daniele l'amico di market
dani rispondimi qualcuno mi risponda ero
allarmatissimo mi sta cagando nelle
mutande veramente ho detto 9 aveva che
si scoprono che se sei stato veramente
tu e questi qua poi alla fine dunque non
visse con i cazzi avvicina e capito
perché fatto una cagata anche se
effettivamente non hai fatto niente di
male perché non è mia e una bambola però
effettivamente uno che inquinamento
perché che cazzo fai e 2 cray allarmismo
quindi secondo me è comunque qualcosa
sbagliato da fare sbagliato comunque a
prescindere quindi un po di realismo lo
crei quindi poi alla fine si scopre che
se se se si scopra che si sta tutto sono
cazzi comunque per il mio nome ciccia
fuori lo stesso guidi buffalo mi
risponde daniele face pronto dani pronto
lo re come stai tutto bene dai istituto
bene c'è un cazzo
rispondimi a questa coppa che daniele
viveva e l'amico di marco vive con marco
ho giocato da cani ma perché insomma
perché faccio schifo giocato organico
approccio schifo avete buttato quella
roba da qualche parte perché guarda
questo articolo che ho trovato è dani mi
rispondi fano non ho assolutamente cioè
varco il ai la sua migliore amica
allora posto non è stato la rivelazione
perché il mio problema era che se usciva
tanto alla fine se qualche scalino poi
prima però se sui giornali esce fuori
marco merlino ha buttato un fiume poi
esci fuori bambola che gli è stata
regalata da e poi esce il nome mio
amicia calmare io ve lo giuro ve lo
giuro è successa sta roba poi veramente
non era la sua perché poi mi ha mandato
le foto fatto vede che sta bene ha posto
però mamma mia a che gianpi e giampiero
hanno chiamato jean pierre japy fi esci
dal video i filmati in faccia e fai
vedere quanto ripagato anche tu perché
anche giampiero la cagato fatti vedere
perché vuol dire fatti vedere cioè nel
senso elspeth ero anch'io che che devo
fare niente
no ragazzi ci abbiamo abbiamo passato un
attimo di di ansia totale totale ho
chiamato già vi ho detto gian marco ha
fatto un casino
cioè se esce fuori poi ci siano fuori i
nostri nomi mamma mia mamma mia
signori spero che vi sia piaciuto a me
no ci diamo cilia
chiudiamo questo video tanto peggio di
così non si può andare
ciao ragazzi
[Musica]